[Musique]
c'est hyper dur comme question
je dirais Henri IV
pour la poule au pot
non je dirais Henri IV il savait à
l'époque il y avait cette affrontement
entre des protestants et les catholiques
il a eu un vrai talent pour réconcilier
les gens pour moi des trucs le plus
important
que j'ai pas réussi je vais être hyper
honnête pendant les 5 ans
mais je m'accroche
c'est à faire que l'angoisse dont on
parle parfois la colère deviennent une
forme d'action coopérative où il y a un
principe de confiance et tout le monde
agit ensemble
c'est vrai c'est hyper et donc c'est ça
que je voudrais réussir à installer les
comme vous savez je dois ma famille en
Irlande et ils ont un chien et je vais
vous montrer comment ce chien il est
vraiment en manque d'affection genre
c'est une Master Class donc là je vous
présente le chien voilà toujours prêt
oui oui toujours prêt à faire des câlins
qu'est-ce que tu fais
regardez quand on arrête trop rire
il est abusé un peu là
du coup ferme la porte
la porte mais toi
il y a une petite fille qui vous aurait
vu porter une perruque sur un marché non
non mais c'est vous mettez les perruque
pour passer une de mes honte ah c'est
vrai mais oui parce que je faisais quel
type de perruque déjà je faisais une
surprise à des amis avec qui je venais
passer le nouvel an et donc je les
rejoignais sur le marché de Nice et donc
pour leur faire la surprise évidemment
j'avais mis une longue période brune en
disant évidemment personne ne va me
reconnaître et à ce moment-là on
avançant il y a une petite fille qui dit
oh regarde maman Marine Le Pen avec une
perruque bon aujourd'hui
et du coup après la deuxième honte
c'était de retirer la perruque devant
tout le monde évidemment donc où les
gens se disent mais qu'est-ce qu'elle
fait avec sa perruque brune
[Rires]
[Musique]